on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on P Morgan sensed Israel
pounds Gaza as Hamas terrorists threaten
more violence 1300 are now feared dead
already tonight Hamas says it will begin
executing hostages Israeli government
has order the Complete Siege of Gaza
cutting off food Fuel and power we'll be
live on the ground and hear from people
on both sides of this divide more than
10 British citizens are feared dead or
missing are talk to a British woman
whose family survived a terrifying
9-hour Siege inside their burning home
also tonight Beckham is back with a
smashit documentary on Netflix is this
the Revival of bran Beckham or is it all
just a load of old Golden Balls we'll
debate
[Music]
that live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan uncensored
well good evening from London welcome to
Pi Morgan uncensored the stories
emerging from Israel are harrowing and
frankly disgusting they represent the
very worst of humanity this can even be
described as human at all more than 900
Israelis have been murdered since Hamas
attacked Israel on Saturday they include
include more than 260 people many young
people massacred at a music festival
there were people with all their lives
ahead of them their dreams intact now
dead or traumatized forever babies and
grandparents have been snatched as
hostages by gunman prowling doorto door
women have been raped next to the
corpses of their friends this is
Medieval barbarism we're witnessing one
of the worst atrocities in Modern Times
And we should be absolutely clear about
this these are acts of unspeakable evil
committed by terrorists there is no
justification no explanation no context
no whaty this is Terrorism as is usually
the case with Israel opportunists have
turned quickly to try to say well okay
what about this what about that what
about this what about the suffering of
the Palestinians at Israel's hands what
about the appalling conditions in Gaza
and yes there are of course significant
broader issues in Israel and they're
subject to ongoing intensely emotive
debate it's a debate I've always tried
to be fair-minded about but what B is
not an acceptable response to terrorism
the people out waving the Palestinian
flag today in London New York and
Manchester they've got this wrong if
they think this is a time to
[Music]
celebrate free fre palese from the river
to the sea from The River To The
[Applause]
Sea well some of those people may well
have the right intentions however
misguided but to parade like that today
there like a celebration of mass murder
Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is undi be dragged his country
into chaos or his attempts to politicize
the Judiciary questions will now be
asked about whether Hamas has exploited
that chaos and pulling off an attack on
a country with one of the most advanced
intelligence operations in the world how
did this happen the Israelis are now
speaking in chilling terms about what
comes next by way of Retribution warning
of enormous force that will change the
region
forever the Israeli Defense Forces will
immediately use all its strength to
destroy hamas's capabilities we will
destroy them and take Mighty Vengeance
for this black day that they have forced
on the state of Israel and its citizens
Israel has every right to defend itself
from this kind of Massacre and Israelis
rightly expect their country to respond
with Force the world is watching in the
expectation The Hope perhaps that its
response will be proportionate although
it's hard to see what proportion is in
this scenario it all frankly uh adds up
to another nightmare in this region and
a lot of innocent people are going to
get killed over the next few weeks and
months tonight Hamas says it will begin
executing hostages unless Israel stops
hitting Gaza well Israel will not stop
hitting Gaza Israeli government has also
B the Complete Siege of Gaza cutting off
food Fuel and power more than 500
Palestinians have been killed in Gaza
since retaliation began that death toll
will rise and Rise more Israelis will
lose their lives too many many innocent
people are going to die here peace
between Israel and Palestine now looks
impossible certainly as far away as it's
ever been perhaps the only cause for
Hope anywhere in this mess is that
people used to say that about Northern
Ireland too until eventually finally
after so much Bloodshed peace was forged
well first tonight a British Israeli
family were trapped for 9 hours with a
10-year-old baby as Hamas terrorists
burned down their house and ransacked
their town close to the Gaza border
Deborah minz originally from ronford
nessex hid in the tiny room with her
grandson Kai and his parents Amy and uel
lean I'm pleased to say they're all safe
and well now and that all of them now
join me live well welcome to all of you
thank you so much I can't even imagine
what you've been through so let me say
that off the the top of this interview
um Deborah let me start with you um for
you this must have been like a nightmare
happening in real
time um yeah even as I look back I find
it very hard to believe that I was
actually
there um yeah it's something in my
wildest dreams I I never thought would
would happen me and de tell just tell
the
audience as best you can remember
exactly what did happen
first of all I want to apologize that
we're copping because of smoke
inhalation so that's the first thing I
want to say we were woken up about 6
6:30 and I'm not 100% on timing it was
about 6 6:30 there was a red siren alert
my daughter and her husband and the baby
were sleeping in the secure room bunker
I suppose you'd call it with a still
door and she screamed at me mom mom come
there's a a siren so I picked myself up
out of bed my little dog wouldn't come
with me he was afraid we picked up the
big dog and off I went into the room we
closed the door now this room is to
protect for Rock from Rockets it's a a
concrete
reinforced room with a steel door and a
steel
window um after about an hour MH we
start we heard gun fire
outside and we realized it it took us
time but eventually we realized that we
were under attack my daughter has
security cameras in her tiny little
house as she looks on her phone and she
screamed at me Mom Mom the terrorists
are in the house they've entered the
house and she and her husband with all
their might kept the handle of the still
door upright so this isn't a door that
locks from inside and that's it it's a
door to protect you from Rockets not
from in in Invaders and
Intruders and they couldn't get us out
they were shooting at the door so they
set fire to the house they switched off
the electricity so we lost the we lost
camera
vision and the the smoke started coming
under the still door into the little
very small small room that where we
were because there was no electricity
there was no air and the window was
closed and from that point we we knew
yeah that's their house we we knew we
were not going to
survive
but from the grace of God I I don't know
how every time we believe that the
terrorists were not around the house
that they've gone to another house we
opened the window we picked the baby up
we put the baby on the window seal we
all got some fresh
air heard the terrorist threw the baby
on the bed closed the still window held
the door and we did this for about six
hours the room was completely filled
with smoke thick black
so
um during this time well very early when
they first started the the fire
I think the worst thing was we heard my
little dog scream but scream as she
burned to
death and I I think I pretty much gave
up after that but for the sake of the
baby you you you try yeah and and then
when we
heard both the kids were on the phone
once orio to his brother Amy to the fire
brigade but they couldn't get to us they
just couldn't get through the
roads and six hours in Smoke pretty much
nine hours from when it started we heard
Hebrew
outside and gunfire and more Hebrew and
then somebody called out Orel and we
said we're here we're here and the Army
came secured the house and got us out
through the
window obviously the baby first with we
were taken to an underground shelter
where other people soon followed but we
heard horrible stories of other people
being shot
disappearing and eventually because
still the ambulances couldn't get in and
we'd all been in a fire we were taken by
by the Army to the hospital which was
well over an hour away and my daughter
and her husband and baby
Kai will release today only today
and today is our reunion I was released
on Saturday night they decided I was
okay it's uh Deborah let me just say
Deborah it's you tell that story it's
making my spine chill listening to what
You' just said um and I'm just so glad
that all of you are still alive let me
let me come to you Amy I mean you must
feel unbelievably fortunate to still be
alive given what you now know was
happening all over the place to other
people
people yeah I mean uh honestly don't
know how we survived how Kai a 10 day
old baby
survive um I guess it's you know you
find the strength to uh to just protect
your family protect
yourself um and we just did what we we
you know our instincts told us to do um
my husband just uh stood by the window
and every time he could he opened it and
we as my mother said we put the baby uh
on the window ledge and try to give him
as much fresh air as possible I mean he
was coughing us up just black spit and
and S and uh and after being so many
hours in Smoke I we literally can't
really see you or or anything uh on the
video because we our eyes are burnt um
hopefully uh we'll get better as the
doctor said it should get
easier
um uh breathing troubles um loads of
medications um yeah but we survived and
so you did I mean it's miraculous that
you've survived and particularly with
this tiny baby uh Orel let me ask you
when this was going on what when you
realized afterwards the scale of what
have been happening what is what is your
response to
this actually I can't believe that we
were caught in this situation I hope
that
um people responsible will give some
answers because I I grew up in this area
since I was 10 years old we were used
to I mean it's awful to say but I'm used
to to Rockets to the siren
to to running to the bomb shelter from
time to time because after all these
years it became the reality where I live
but this what happened to us this
Saturday was in a whole other scale and
honestly I
didn't ever believe that we will go
through something like this it was
something else never never was something
like that I think since Israel state was
founded
yeah I mean this is the worst this is
the worst Slaughter of predominantly
Jewish people since the Holocaust I mean
there's no other way to describe this
nearly 900 people or more now apparently
uh were killed in this and it's ongoing
um do you fear now let me ask you Amy
this do you fear that this is now going
to be a a raging War for some time to
come and what will you do as a
family um well I honestly don't know how
to answer that I mean I I hope we'll get
through
this um I hope it won't get any
worse um we just uh are trying now to uh
figure out what's what's next for us and
where we going to live for I know the
next uh weeks or months
year um we literally just lost
everything um I mean I'm glad to say my
my dog managed to escape the safe room
because we weren't allowed to take her
with us she somehow managed to escape
and survive and she was found and
brought to us um so I am happy about
that um my dog not so lucky no I'm so
sorry what was what was your dog's name
Deborah Nikky he had big ears like
Mickey mouth and what what was Mickey's
breed um
sort of like a little miniature Doberman
Piner that barked a lot and slept by my
feet here he is
yeah I'm so sorry about about Mickey I'm
so sorry um about everything that's
happened to you uh I just want to say to
all three of you thank you for taking
the the time and trouble to speak to me
in such uh open and graphic manner I
think you really brought it home to
people what it must have been like
utterly terrifying I'm so glad you're
all still alive I'm glad that little
Kai's
okay and you've had the treatment you
need and I wish you all the very best in
rebuilding your lives because like you
say everything's gone up right you have
nothing um but I wish you all the very
best and thank you for joining me just
mention something please yes that we
there is a go fundme set up to help Amy
and Orel rebuild
lives um I don't know how I'm supposed
to don't worry I I'll tell you what I'll
do Deborah I will tweet that and I've
got uh over 8 million Twitter followers
so I'll make sure that we tweet that out
so people can try and help you
okay your producer thank you very very
much for having okay thank you all very
much I wish you all the very best and
thank you again for joining me thank you
thank
you quite extraordinary account there
from people who are just very lucky to
be alive and since next I talked to two
people on opposite sides of this Israel
Palestine
divide
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to pleas senstive a more on
the situation on the ground I'm joined
now from the Israel Gaza border by Fox
News correspondent Trey INX well Trey
I've been following your reporting all
day first of all astounding journalism
you're doing there under extremely
difficult uh conditions so thank you
once again uh you are one of the best in
the world at this but tell me with all
your experience of everything you've
seen what do you make of this this last
48 hours and where's it all going to
go Pierce thank you I've covered a lot
of conflicts all around the world and
many conflicts between Israel and Gaza
this level of brutality is unprecedented
it was not a combatant on combatant
fight Hamas and Islamic Jihad militants
entered in their early morning hours
going to a music festival and mowing
down 260 people before going to
communities along the Gaza border and
slaughtering civilians women and
children in their homes and we've seen
the scenes of this we were here in the
hours as The Invasion into Southern
Israel started and we watched as mothers
brought their injured children to
waiting ambulances crying and looking
into the blooded faces of their kids and
we saw as soldiers tried to resuscitate
their friends
unsuccessfully we have seen just the
trauma the Israeli people are
experiencing and will continue to
experience as a result of what happened
the latest death toll stands at more
than 900 people and in addition to that
there are dozens of hostages captives
prisoners of War taken into the Gaza
Strip and Hamas the group in control of
Gaza says they are keeping them in the
tunnels beneath the strip where they
store rockets and ammunition making it
even more difficult for the Israelis as
they conduct more than a thousand air
strikes against positions all throughout
Gaza Pierce trade how did this happen
Israel famously has one of the best
defense systems supposedly in the world
one of the best homeland security
systems the scale of this is so
overwhelming it begs a question how on
Earth has this happened without the
Israeli security and Defense Forces is
picking up on
it it's a great question this border
between Israel and Gaza was touted for
years by the Israelis as one of the most
advanced in the world they took our team
there and showed us where they dug steel
plates into the ground so that tunnels
couldn't be uh dug into Israel they put
sensors on the tops of concrete walls
with barbed wire they have surveillance
balloons and drones overhead
247 and the fact that Hamas and Islamic
Jihad were able to infiltrate at 20
different locations along the border is
stunning and terrifying and the
population here was not expecting this
there was no advanced notice no
indication about a pending threat
against the Israeli people and Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu in his
address tonight to the nation and to the
world indicated there are still Hamas
Fighters inside Israel we were in the
town of sto where we're at today in
front of the police station yesterday
reporting and it appeared the area was
clear of Hamas Fighters and as the
evening hours set in reports came in of
gun battles in these streets and so it's
a very fluid and unpredictable situation
and the Israeli Security Forces
understand there are still Palestinian
militants in the southern part of this
country pier and obviously we now know
there's going to be ferocious
retribution Revenge from Israel uh do
you think that will include a ground war
land forces going in it's always
something that they've resisted doing
but is Netanyahu under such pressure now
internally to do something spectacular
by way of what they would see as
proportionate response so that is more
likely absolutely and as you noted in
the past even during Wars with Gaza
especially prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has been hesitant about
sending forces in because in the past it
has been very difficult and bloody for
the Israelis it is hard to occupy
portions of Gaza in that manner with
soldiers on every street corner and
tanks and apcs because Hamas and Islamic
Jihad militants know this area they're
fighting on their home turf and they
have the Weaponry for urban battle but
given what's happened the slaughter of
so many innocent civilians
the taking captive of women and children
grandmothers innocent people it leaves
the Israeli Prime Minister really with
no choice it is almost certain that
Israel will enter Gaza and we have seen
every indication to point to just that
Israeli tanks are staging in the fields
around this town that we're in right now
there are thousands of soldiers today
Israel's defense minister yav Galant
indicated 300,000 reservists have been
called up and hundreds of thousands
remain in the wings but there is this
concern also that the southern front may
not be the only front Israel is facing
piar yeah it's a it's a very scary
situation Trey continue your great work
but please stay safe out there it looks
a dangerous dangerous time to be a
journalist I've seen some I've seen some
extraordinary scenes today I've seen
correspondents break down in tears I've
seen others leaping to save themselves
from rocket attacks it is dangerous but
you guys do such an important job
bringing the the truth on the ground to
the to the world so thank you and keep
it up but stay safe like I
said well for more I'm joined from rala
in the West Bank uh by the Palestinian
initiative leader Mustafa bouti Mr bti
thank you for joining me um it's very
hard when you look at the scale of what
has happened here uh not to believe that
this is a a
reprehensible terrorist attack by a
bunch of Med evil barbarians when I say
that what is your
response first of all let me say that
I'm really sorry about what happened to
deora's Family I'm glad they are
safe if I can contribute to relieving
their suffering I am ready to do
so uh that's one side of the issue but
what I would like you to know and I want
the audience to know is that what they
described is exactly what happened to
many Palestinian families uh only 3
months ago when Israeli illegal settlers
attacked their houses and burned them
these were American Palestinians from
the village of
tmos and singel and huara and they
almost face the same story their houses
burned their cars burned by fanatic
Israeli illegal
settlers in this situation I'm a medical
doctor as you know and I learned that
the best treatment of a patient is not
only to look at the symptoms but at the
causes of the problem and while we are
talking Gaza now is under
bombardment Gaza is taking actually
Netanyahu is taking Gaza the whole of
Gaza 2.2 million people people as a
hostage uh cutting water cutting
electricity cutting medicines cutting
food from them the acts of collective
punishment against 2.2 million
Palestinians is not at the the right
response uh and this will lead to more
problems but the cause problem of what
we see here is 56 years of military
Israeli occupation of Palestinian land
the fact that Netanyahu blocked every
possibility for a peaceful resolution of
this conflict he blocked Oso agreement
he fought against it he aggravated
people against itak Rin who was
assassinated after signing Oslo
agreement and the result is what we see
today a protracted problem the only way
out of this situation so that no
Palestinian or Israeli would suffer is
to end the Israeli illegal occupation in
the system of apartheid and I'm not
saying that my by my own words these are
the words of Amnesty International and
Human Rights Watch and even the Israeli
human rights organization bit Salem and
the system of aperti that Palestinians
are subjected to you know I watched you
um if I may just jump in there I I I
watched you do an interview with an old
colleague of mine Fred zakari at CNN and
you said many similar things and it was
it was a thoughtful interview it was
conducted respectfully but you said one
thing there which I wanted to challenge
you on now which is you said that uh in
these attacks Hamas did not Target
civilians I mean that is clearly
completely untrue they deliberately
targeted civilians would you like to
retract that
statement No I said that Hamas attacked
started by attacking military stations
and obviously there were attacks on
civilians which we don't accept and we
don't agree with uh as much as we don't
agree now with what the Israeli air
strikes are doing to Gaza striking
civilian population killing so far 700
people and I am sure by tomorrow morning
it will be 2,000 people killed but just
to
clarify just to clarify you do now
accept they were targeting civilians
because you didn't accept that on CNN no
I said I I didn't have the full
information I know now that some
civilians were killed and this is
unacceptable some civilians I mean 260
young mainly young people well let me
just say something 260 mainly young
people attending a peaceful music
festival were machine guns machine gun
to their death by by terrorists flying
in paragliding in with machine guns I
mean it is hard to imagine a worse
atrocity do you unreservedly condemn
that act of terrorism I do not not
accept killing any civilian but would
you tell me that the Israeli soldiers
that have killed today 140 Palestinian
children and 105 Palestinian women are
also terrorists I think that the Israeli
I think the Israeli people are entitled
to defend themselves against what
happened in the last 48 hours I'm not
defend I'm Not For a Moment defending
everything the Israeli government's done
in the last few Decades of course I've
always where it's been Justified
criticized what they've been doing uh
but on this occasion I'm not interested
in playing water with you I'm simply
asking do you I'm simply asking you do
you unreservedly condemn the slaughter
26 I condemn I condemn any killing of
any civilian whether Palestinian or
Israeli but you have to accept that if
Israel has the right to defend itself
Palestinians also must have the same
right of being able to defend nobody has
a right to Comm nobody has a right to
commit Act
age with that would you say no I am
asking would you say that we also have
the right to defend ourselves as as
human beings I think that there has been
an oppression of the Palestinian people
in Gaza for way too long I think that
there needs to be a peace settlement we
finally got there we finally got there
in Northern Ireland but I don't
understand how anybody with even half a
brain would think the way to get a peace
settlement is to kill nearly a thousand
mostly innocent Israelis who have
nothing to do with the conflict many of
whom were attending a music festival and
get machine gun to Pieces there is no
way there is no way that kind of that
kind of attack is ever going to forge
peace is that absolutely but uh let's
look forward now at this very moment
there are hostages uh there are
Palestinian prisoners in Israeli jails
there are Israeli prisoners in Gaza the
best step forward is the following
immediate exchange of prisoners
immediate stop of all the fighting
immediate ceasefire and opening the road
for what you have said something like
what happened in Ireland ending the
Israeli illegal occupation allowing
Palestinians finally to be free from
oppression and to live side by side I
personally wouldn't mind if we could
live side by side in two-state solution
but if Israel kills the two states
option I think the only solution is that
we live together in one country in
peaceful can I ask you I know you're not
in in one in one Democratic State I know
you're not a where where we both have
equal rights yeah and we both have are
entitled to the same equal human rights
uh I think that's the only way out of
this situation and you you we cannot say
I mean I could list to you now uh so
many atrocities let me tell you one
thing from my own personal experience
once in 1996 I was treating an injured
person I was a medical person in my
white coat and an Israeli sniper saw me
and shot me twice I still carry 35 shels
in my back but I don't keep talking
about that I think the way out of this
is to is to stop all forms of violence
to stop all f forms of conflict and to
allow a peaceful resolution but here's
the thing that peaceful peace let me
just respond to that you know when I
watched your interview at CNN and I hear
you again tonight you sound a reasonable
man who wants a reasonable solution to
this right I'm not going to I'm not
going to disrespect you by saying
otherwise the problem is Hamas are not
reasonable people they're not like you
they just want to kill as many Jews as
they can possibly kill they have no
interest in the kind of resolution that
you're talking about and Hamas now has a
strangle hold over the Gaza Strip and
the Palestinian people as long as they
have that strangle hold with their
concept of how this plays out there is
no chance of the settlement you're
talking about do you accept that may may
I respond yeah I know Hamas people I've
negotiated with them so many times I've
debated with them many times about the
value and power of nonviolent resistance
and I tell you they are ready to accept
two State solution they are ready to
accept that what they would what they
are not ready to accept is that we
Palestinians will repeat what the PLO
leadership did recognizing Israel as a
state while Israel still refuses to
recognize our right as a state you know
one of the main problems that Netanyahu
created and I think this man will be
definitely put in front of many
inquiries about what happened in the
last two days or three days but one of
the worst things he did was to stand up
in the United Nations only two weeks ago
carrying the map of Israel including
annexing the occupied West Bank annexing
the occupied Gaza Strip annexing the
occupied East Jerusalem as well as the
Golan Heights which Israeli officially
annexed this map by itself drove
everybody crazy that meant that he and
his government with people like smotrich
who doesn't hide away calling himself a
fascist homophobe they say that we
should fill the West Bank with settlers
and settlements so that Palestinian
would lose all hopes of a state of their
own okay and then will they then they
will have one of three choices either to
immigrate or accept a life of
subjugation to the Israelis or die such
statement by the second most important
minister in the Israeli government does
not lead to peace and that's what that
point on that point on that point Mr I I
would agree with you I think some of the
more Hardline right-wing Headbangers
frankly that netanyahu's put him put
into his cabinet are uh coming out with
incend rhetoric before this which has
been deeply unhelpful so on that I would
agree with you I've got to leave it
there but thank you for joining me I
appreciate it thank you thank you for
giving giving me the opportunity it's
important to hear that side and I I
appreciate it uh for more now I'm joined
from Tel by the former Israeli
ambassador to the UK uh Mark reg Mark um
we've talked many times over the years
of varying stages of this conflict never
in in the wake of such an appalling
atrocity and just to be clear if you
work listening earlier but I view this
as a heinous terror attack by terrorists
um what is your response to what has
happened and what is the proportionate
response that we should see from
Israel so obviously it was a very very
difficult uh day for us s day I mean we
keep finding bodies but we're we're
close close now to a
thousand casualties fatalities in
Israel they crossed the border they
entered our communities uh agricultural
communities U urban communities and they
just gunned people down in the streets I
mean this has been reported widely I
don't have to repeat it they came across
the border to kill as many people as
they could and uh kidnap take back to
Gaza uh people as hostages and and and
they took women they took children they
took the
elderly even a a holocaust Survivor um
it was a terrible day for Israel a
severe
blow uh I don't think it gets tougher my
prime minister has called it Israel's
911 but if you think about it Israel is
what 9 million people and we we've lost
close to a thousand people from
proportional proportional point of view
if you look at you know the you know
America is over 300 million people it's
it's a much it's a much tougher
blow Mark I was speaking to a a
Palestinian earlier and he was making
the point uh forcefully that there has
been decades now of strikes and counter
strikes attacks and counterattacks
there's no completely innocent party
here I don't think this is the moment to
talk about water bouty because of the
scale of this terror attack but how does
peace get forged now in light of the
scale of this I mean it is hard to see
how any peace will be achievable in the
near to Mid
future so I think to answer your
question fairly I I would argue and to
pick up on what you said to the previous
guest is it has to be understood that
Hamas are not just Israel's enemy Hamas
are the enemies of peace and
Reconciliation and if you read their
Charter they say openly any Palestinian
who negotiates with Israel is a traitor
any Palestinian who makes a compromise
with Israel is a traitor uh they're
against accepting Israel they said
openly in any
borders Hamas are the enemies of Peace
uh uh what we saw in their brutal
Behavior the way they treat Tre the
civilian population just gunning people
down and so forth they were behaving
like
Isis and that's that's that's the mode
that they're
in and they've turned Gaza into a a
massive Terror
base and and it's and I think it has to
be understood that if we want to move
forward in
peace Hamas has to be defeated and for
me it's very uh uh disappointing though
unfortunately not surprising that
so-called moderate Palestinians will
justify Hamas instead of condemning them
if Britain can condemn Kamas if Nations
across Europe can condemn Kamas why
can't Palestinians who profess to be
moderate condemn Hamas after all Hamas
is recognized by your government by my
government by the United States by
Canada by Japan by the European Union as
a terrorist organization
that's what they are and anyone who had
any doubts about that could just see how
they behaved on on on satday morning
yeah I I think you cannot get away from
the fact that this this is a terrorist
organization committing grotesque acts
of Terror and we've just seen the most
grotesque uh today uh Mark R thank you
very much indeed for joining me I
appreciate
it on since the next the Pierce Pat
returns to debate the unfolding events
in Israel and the rest of the day's
news
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King pi and King C I
think there's only room for one king man
you know what I'm saying he's mocked
your weight Trump yeah look at him fail
stop working just cuz they're skin folk
don't mean they're kin folk do you
believe you can win this war making me
cry again to force you out yes I feel
betray keep it
awardwinning Lucy Ley will die behind
bars and a senior Doctor Who first
raised concerns about Ley once NHS
manages to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what s
years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous he was clearly
something of the face of the ward so
even more Unthinkable if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katy that would make her a
better princess of well cuz you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people gay
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I he wish I'd never met
him the conservative party can certainly
win the next election can we yes
lab9
the did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things the rest of the world has watched
on in sort of mounting horror as this
story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal the death toll from
the Titanic tragedy has risen to 1522
and may God Rest their
[Music]
souls let it
roll
y if we stop producing oil the knock on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
boot me off
CH some of them they're easily
L you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you that
you'd be worried about so are you saying
that you're being overwhelmed that
you're inundated we are really working
hard for you we're just asking patients
to be patient with us we're now in
Barbie world you weren't asked to give
evidence to the grand jury I'm the only
one that has been telling the truth you
don't drink never taken drugs you're
stinking Rich should we be
concerned if it's on your mind it's on
talk TV is about you and your opinions
if you're thinking about it we're
talking about it
it's all about me that a
[Music]
joke this is talk
TV welcome back to uncensored by py with
me the Socialist nor Grace blin talk to
contributor Esther KY right so Grace
this is horrendous what happened was
horrendous the retribution is going to
be horrendous this spiral of violence
continues what do you make of this what
I make of it is that the violence that
we're seeing at the moment is you know
put in place and encouraged by the fact
that there is so little knowledge and
understanding of what is going on in
Palestine and the crimes that are being
committed there every day if like me you
know people in Palestine you know
journalists working in Palestine you
know uh human rights organizations
working there your news feed every day
will be full of videos of um isra of
Israeli troops harming civilians killing
children often we know that
6,400 Palestinians have been killed
since 2008 by nothing justifies the
scale of this this is Isis level
terrorism what you're saying this is not
just a Revenge attack here when you put
to me a question like that it's the
equivalent of saying you know there's a
man who's in a house he's got his whole
family there another guy comes in kicks
him out of his house locks him in the
cellar kills his family says you're not
coming out all of his neighbors say oh
yeah you're right to keep him in there
and just ignore the situation suddenly
the man comes up busts out says I'm you
know I'm going to get rid of all of this
stuff I'm burning the house down lots of
people die and then the only way that
you look at situation is by saying oh
let's condemn the Mad in the C yes
condemn the Mad in the C but condemn The
Who KCK him out have to look at what is
in the best interest of innocent
Palestinians that are not reacting in
this way I'm not disputing the fact that
obviously there is a lot wrong with the
situation between Israel and Palestine
but the idea that you know by attacking
by murdering 700 Israeli citizens 900
now well 9 00 now you're you're
inherently acting in the best interest
of innocent who I I I I've often said I
absolutely I'm I'm horrified by the
appli over half of the population of
Palestine is under the age of 25 an
entire generation this is all they've
ever the problem is Hamas are annihilist
Terror
organization that have been empowered by
the collapse of the center ground and
why has that happened that has been
aided and abetted by this astonishingly
right-wing conservative government that
we've seen in Israel I can agree with
that and I when I interviewed Nan I put
that to him I can agree with that there
are lots of issues there the social
unrest in Israel because of their
attempts to try and basically diminish
the are saying the Israeli intelligence
services are saying we have been warning
you the Israeli government that if you
continue to allow Israeli settlers to
murder Palestinians this will cause a
security threat and now people are
saying this is Chicken and the Egg I
just don't think anyone on a day like
this can start getting into the other
stuff so quickly before you say this
this is disgusting what makes me so sad
is that of course it's disgusting but
there are so many abuses and violations
and just horrible an Israeli child shot
in the back running away from Israeli
forces after been throwing rocks that
literally just happened
recently resp Iran because Iran clearly
clearly funded well Iran is clearly
funding lot this responsibity we' a lot
lot of the show on on this issue it's
not going to go away this will be raging
now for weeks months um I fear years um
let's just switch to something else I'll
just caught my eye on the news David
Williams is now suing the makers of
Britain's Got Talent uh for 10 million
pounds after he got five for being
caught on tape bad mouthing contestants
but one line got my line he he's
apparently he said he has had active
Suicidal Thoughts but also that it's Lo
he's lost the ability to be funny and
when I read that I was like when did he
have the ability to be funny yeah this
is assuming he was I have never found
him funny in my entire life
missing yeah was he ever there for
comedic relief I I didn't I didn't I
didn't get the memo there but I'm just
wondering which of the powers that be at
ITV did he really annoy to have that
that's what I was thinking because I I
don't think you'd be on the Simon car
Christmas card has he ever made you
laugh Williams oh I don't know I haven't
really watched very much of a stuff I
just find it really annoying this
weaponization of mental health of do
especially celebrities when they are you
know for exactly and they play it
deliberately to get people on their side
and other people off their back we got
to leave it there thank you both very
much indeed great to see you uh I know
you're going to C more soon I am I will
come back every now and again keep
leaving us when I'm done surfing and
since the next T night as Beckham
becomes the new number one documentary
on Netflix I ask if it gives us a fresh
insight into Posh and be or is it just
more cynical cyclical myth making by the
Undisputed king and queen of
[Music]
self-promotion
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back David Beckham's back with a
new Netflix documentary in it we learned
that beckam was supposedly a once in a
generation footballer Posh and Beck are
described by Gary Neville with his
straight face as the Charles and din of
sport they CA has lots of learning about
the press the fans and his various
managers so is it all a load of old
Golden Balls we here to decide is the
man who brought Beck into LA Galaxy
Alexi Lis and podcaster James B right
Alexi hit me with it then because I've
always found these two a bunch of
self-promoting wiers who basically
exploit every situation for personal
financial gain
discuss yeah I mean I don't think that
the documentary is going to change uh
your opinion of them but I think get
kind of set out to humanize David and
Victoria for that matter and I think in
a sense it does I think it makes them a
little bit more likable whether you're
seeing you know David putter around with
his bees and his honey or on barbecue or
his OCD when it comes to his clothes um
but I also think that there's some
misses so it's it's it's entertainment
um and I think ultimately you get a
glimpse into what David Beckham is but
only the Glimpse that he and Victoria
and David Beckham the machine wants you
to get up right and James that's my
issue with it is that this is a very
sanitizing thing it's a bit like the
Megan and Harry Netflix one what all
we're getting is basically a PR job I
mean I love Megan and Harry and I think
the documentary was pivotal uh however
this horrific but this documentary is so
boring I mean Rebecca L isn't even named
which she's my second cousin incredible
really yes there's a bombshell wow yeah
well she's not named so I imagine she
feels this is quite disrespectful she's
one of the most interesting things also
David Beckham really betrayed the lgbtq
plus Community when he worked with Qatar
he last week said that it was actually a
safe place for LGBT people even though
people are murdered for being gay there
so it does strike me as a bit shocking
that he didn't sort of bring up how part
of brand Beckham was built he wasn't
really challenged about anything
substantive I mean it was interesting to
hear them talk and you know I mean
Beckham was a good footballer but Alexi
I've always felt that he's overrated in
the pantheon of great players he's a
good player but he was never a great
great
player yeah but he was you know arguably
and maybe still is one of the most
famous people on the planet and I think
that's another thing that the
documentary doesn't really delve into is
this brand I think I find it as
interesting as the actual player on the
field and to your point look we all know
a titilating part is the affair and the
alleged cheating and all that and if
you're going to bring it up I don't know
but after watching it I turned around
and said wait that's it because they
kind of just veered off into something
else and it never actually was addressed
I get it it's personal if you don't want
to talk about it that's fine but if
you're going to talk about it in the
documentary then there's got to be
something definitive and the intentional
vagueness in that moment I think was
Stark and he missed opportunity and one
that really stands out what what is
Beckham's reputation in America now
what' you
say now I think with the ownership that
he has with inter Miami and now bringing
Messi I think there's one of business I
think there's one of startup I also
think that he in the history of American
soccer his coming to Major League Soccer
and to the United States I do think that
it's looked at as a seminal and
rightfully and fairly so a seminal type
of moment that changed the structure and
the league I don't think that he's
looked at in the same way that for
example P when he came and played in the
NSL looked and to your point about about
the player Messi has always been about
on the field uh and what he does on the
field David has been about everything on
the field and off the field and and
James Victoria Beckham and all this how
does she come over do you oh I mean it's
so unrelatable that she had her dad
drive her to school in a Rolls-Royce and
the fact that she's trying to hide that
is hilarious listen I love Victoria
Beckham I've always loved the Spice
Girls I'm a spice boy I also think
that's what's upsetting about this
documentary like it's more about him I
just don't really care I want to see
Victoria Beckham getting back to what
she does best and what she does best is
pointing in the spice go so can we
please get a Reunion yeah I wouldn't
mind a Spice Girls reunion uh I wouldn't
mind that actually be quite fun um but
they couldn't have any autot tuning
they'd have to actually be heard singing
as they actually sing uh James Alexi
good debate thank you both I appreciate
it Ginger Spice baby Ginger
Spice that's it for me keep it un
[Music]
sensed
good evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in
New York City King pi and King QBE I
think there's only room for one king man
you know what I'm saying he's mocked
your weight Trump yeah look at him fail
stop working just cuz they're skin folk
don't mean they're kin folk do you
believe you can win this war making me
cry again they're trying to force you
out yes I feel betray keep it
awardwinning m Lucy Ley will die behind
bars and a senior Doctor Who first
raised concerns about Le wants NHS
manages to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what s
years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous it was clearly
something of the face of the ward so
even more Unthinkable if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katy that would make her a
better princess of well cuzz you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people gay
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I he wish I'd never met
him the conservative party can certainly
win the next election can we yes
lab9
the did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things the rest of the world has watched
on in sort of mounting horror as this
story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal the death toll from
the Titanic tragedy has risen to 1522
and may God Rest their
souls let it roll
yo